hey guys um I'm Greg Alba and I'm just
on people think I've lost my mind
recently and I'm here to assure them
that I have it I think everything is
good in life and everything is positive
and I believe in all religions even the
ones that contradict themselves
I believe in it all now I'm keeled
anyway guys we're gonna check out the
trailer for lights out lights out lights
out guerrilla radio wait whose movie is
this I don't know the guys name I know
it this was names one involved in
someone James ones producing it okay
it's the short that was going around
Facebook for ages where the woman's in
the hallway she turns out the light
there's like a shape and then she turns
it back on and it's gone it freaked
everybody out and that little little
short has been expanded into a future
food oh yeah that's exciting the guy
shares a name with the same guy who made
come fury totally different people but
they have the same name there's a fun
fact them all right there's not gonna
speak on these no it's okay you can you
guys think you think
oh it's Melissa McCarthy get closer get
closer [ __ ] stop every time I turn off
the light here's this seven yeah oh [ __ ]
latent shadows I see her - on our red
light you just eat your life one of us
is being haunted by this thing
huh hey Martin what's up did we wake you
what long time ago I had a friend he
died
and something really bad happened to her
everyone is afraid of the dark
that's what she feeds on show yourself
Becca
no we need to find more like
Wow just this trailer alone here's me
not want to turn my lights huh yeah
that's a very good ever thing to make a
horribly scary trailer what is
universally terrifying the dark yeah
even if you're not afraid of it the
second you turn off some lights at night
after you've seen this movie it's good
across your mind I mean just thought
that lady at the beginning was dumb I
feel like they they intentionally omage
the short cuz it's the short is
literally a woman in the hall doing the
up-and-down trick a bunch of times
that's a clearly like just being like
hey guys it's us I'm curious about how
that scene will actually play out some
kind of dumb you're gonna like oh this
thing appears when the lights are off
well in the original short-legged
the context is a little bit like she's
getting ready for bed and it's a very
intimate setting that's like this is
your place of work don't turn that light
back on just run away yeah you know so I
get I get where you're coming from it's
kind of simple to defeat this ghost
though or whatever it is that's what I'm
gonna keep the lights on yeah that's
what I'm curious about how a real better
than that yeah yeah yeah I'm curious
about what the other mythologies they've
clearly expanded like in the short you
have no idea what this thing is so
they've clearly expanded on it and
that's what I'm very curious to see
because I feel like this could either be
like really cool and clever or kind of
silly yeah that whole like I had a
friend and some really terrible [ __ ]
happen to my friend like you see cuz
yeah one thing I was gain from this is
horror movie acting but I liked with
James Wan when he's like actually
directing is his films tend to have just
characters yeah and this seems like
horror movie dialogue horror movie okay
yeah it's just a trailer so that could
be totally wrong I mean it definitely
looks like a lot of crazy [ __ ] happens
like this is the thing like even though
I was teetering on like this could be
silly or this could not like still most
of the scenes we saw I was like this
looks really creepy there's some
fucked-up [ __ ] in the basement that
looks cool like everything looks really
cool I just hope the script is also cool
and look I don't want to be racist but
I'm gonna point out the racism of this
movie
oh [ __ ] really in this trailer I don't
know if in the movie it's gonna be this
way yeah looks like the the black guy
died first oh the cop yeah black cop um
maybe I don't know me
I agree he's the only black character I
think we saw in that trailer so sadly
you could be right yeah
unfortunately and there was another like
an image of the cop and like he looked
like a something was up with his face Oh
probably there's like during the last
montage of the trailer and maybe I
probably did like that's a really cool
editing approach to that trailer because
like that whole clicking motif I was
like yeah I don't even care like I
probably won't make it in the movie that
same way when I was like this is very
cool for a trailer and all that like
eight millimeter footage whenever I see
that in anything it just creeps me out
even if it's like Raging Bull when they
did it for ten minutes I was still like
there's something creepy about a male it
was driving when you're like some kind
of icky Hospital yeah always it's not an
asylum of some sort yeah like that was
always the best stuff in like the house
in Haunted Hill remake in the 30 goes
and I would like flashback and you'd be
like ooh
like you know icky Asylum and I like how
when they showed a photo of like I had a
friend and then it's like the normal
girl in her yeah yeah they're like she's
always like Krieger the bread just
clearly [ __ ] how did you not notice is
all your fault you should stop being
friends with her or got her some help
and I'm sure this one will have its
differences but you know there is
darkness falls similarities for sure
yeah I mean using using the idea of
light and darkness as your safety yeah
and there's gonna be people are gonna be
like it's deserved Jean looks different
fraid of the dark is like a universal
thing and like that term is supposed to
like it had a very different school I'd
like it was a monster and we also knew
it was like oh the Tooth Fairy is coming
for you this has the added like oh we
don't know who this woman is or why yeah
yeah there's a lot of Universal fears
darkness snakes clowns uh Joe Pesci
commitment am i right ladies uh uh joke
about jokes from sitcoms
I had the Joe Pesci punchline I'm just
like I'm gonna throw my punch like I
just feel like I live whatever the heck
I'm down what the heck happened to this
whole like we're gonna be Whittier and
work better off each other kind of
common I'm trying to be witty don't try
do
trying is the beginning of failing
sounds like it don't I don't ever try
trying is the beginning of nail yet
you're fired
yeah me I'm gonna wait to like to see
what you got to say about this movie
yeah yeah I'm not this isn't something
where I'm like it's like conjuring to
that trailer was like I'm gonna be in
theater this one was like yeah I could
wait to see what some people are saying
well cuz this is also make it or break
it movie for David Sandberg you know
this is I think this is his first
feature and I mean he's gotten a very
nice boost because James Wan jumped on
Borden and like this is a mood like this
is getting above release you know Victor
Lee seems like be funny if you turn the
lights off in John Goodman from 10
Cloverfield Lane that very frightening
yeah that would be but a John Goodman
that would be even more frightening
because you're like why is this child
man in here like now I'm alarmed and I
don't know how you snuck in anyway guys
listen know if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and be come up
reject alright and way I'm supposed to
say something about you right oh I have
a playlist with my stuff on it that I'm
in yeah on this channel and on this
channel and also I we do podcasts yeah
Aaron Danko Stubbs me Reese's to Jerry
dankest um that's my dad
for now it's my stuff yeah and we have a
Facebook um I have an Instagram he has
an Instagram at Twitter Ian Twitter yeah
you could follow us there because you
know stay interactive that way yeah yeah
yeah um get in touch with ya you know
they say every uh every online
personality needs to have one of those
yeah yeah yeah we're going to in order
to be successful in anything
pimp your brand yeah exactly exactly we
are like diet soda what's up cat this is
real life right here this is what
happens behind the movie mesh and ah
dude no don't go
God you touch odd smell like kitty
litter No and now copper is all like
look I'm on your love - dad you can't
pick a favorite no no - what no no one
ain't cocky fun alright no Todd's like
I'm I eat this Bookman these are my
cat's John I know let them all he knows
was a camera all right - y'all have a
good night
Merry Christmas and yeah and God bless
us everyone
food both like one good across the back